i'm sorry sorry sorry right uh my
goodness me uh right first of all
welcome to ramsey in ten uh so nice to
see you thank you for tuning in live now
i know i travel fast work fast do
everything fast so i need to slow down
but before we start i'd like to say a
big very special thank you to all those
essential workers especially the nhs
you're doing an incredible job also i'd
like to mention the actual live they're
saving okay which is incredible numbers
for thank you and having a mum that's
worked as a nurse i know what you're
going through
continue it honestly now ramsey in 10
we're going to cook an amazing dinner in
10 minutes but first of all put your
pans on don't put the oil in there don't
put any salt in there just get your pan
put it on the gas
and turn the freaking thing on that is
it leave that to get warm i've got a
timer because when i say 10 minutes i do
mean 10 minutes yes i do waffle baked i
know you makes sort of shouting at me
but before we start cooking
you know today's a very special day
because this time tolerance again here
they're clattering in the background
it's somebody's birthday now
let's start off this cook along live
singing a very happy birthday to our
dear beloved son oscar who is one today
but it may be your birthday as well it
could be a birthday tomorrow could be a
birthday yesterday but let's celebrate
this incredible cook along and start
singing happy birthday mate even even
the dog's joining in now where is he
where is he where is he where is he
where he's isn't he he is in the kitchen
oscar hey
happy birthday to you
happy birthday
[Applause]
okay god bless him dude happy birthday i
know you're upset because i just pulled
you out in the kitchen that is why here
we are all right
here's the cake
uh how do you have the blog ready ready
one two two
three
make a wish
make your wish god bless
peace um okay now let's go uh now um
there's no hair there's no makeup
there's no there's no there's no
production crew let me show you who the
production are these are the super
talented ramsey girls uh head of d.o.p
director of production and she's an
amazing uh camera woman and she does
know her stuff let me tell you that's
megan ramsey second uh dp who is second
let's smile kid
it's the one
matilda thank you so much and i've seen
this whole thing and put it together the
glue behind the girls holly
holly thank you for lending your light
uh ladies thank you so much and where's
me man
he's back in the kitchen
dude
right dad come on come on let's go right
let's go give me the camera back there
yes
right first of all let's set the timer
shall we for 10 minutes yes
now any questions uh just shout first of
all
marinate the lamb okay touch the
sunflower oil
little sprinkle of oil a lot of fat on
this lamb these are lamb chops okay
lightly seasoned i always mix pan down
please make pan down
i always mix the salt
ready oh
oh no
so there's a lot of fat on that lamb so
season it pan down please make that
means bring the camera down okay of all
the plate lightly seasoned sunflower oil
and just gently season that okay
pans are on i'm not gonna put any um oil
in there it's gonna get nice and hot the
secret here i'm gonna grill those lamb
chops look how thin they are got a
beautiful eye of the meat that fat
around the backside is gonna be sort of
rendered down that is delicious
next to that i've got these new potatoes
now we had these with dinner last night
so they're sort of left over ball
potatoes and all we do is get them
cut them in half okay
and the nice thing about these
is they're actually going to
sort of become like a sauteed potato
okay pan down leg pan down meg please
pan down thank you come on meg we're
live
seriously
i can't have 15 fingers coming at once
first off start the lamb okay
now i've got the water on boiling
salt and pepper in there as well i was
trying to say earlier i mixed the salt
and pepper so i just seasoned it once
okay it's actually two-thirds salt and
one-third pepper so it's a light
sprinkling lid on
peas they are fresh frozen peas it's the
best way of making an amazing puree once
that starts the smoke if you haven't got
one of those griddle pans trust me a
normal pan will be fine
a little touch of oil in there just a
touch because we've already put it on
the lamb already
and then from there look
rubbing the seasoning
in and just lightly push them down now
go left to right
okay
left to right
and get them grilling
beautifully
done
now if you get any big thick chops like
that push them in
and literally just push them down with
your fingers okay
they're still cold they're not going to
burn but just push them in there
scrape all that seasoning off
now
it's on there watch your fingers
and then how do we get that a little bit
more exciting with that get some garlic
okay
a couple of cloves of garlic make hand
left please come there don't worry don't
worry about pinging or chopping knife
down nice and flat palm of the hand
and down all you do is cross pan
down that's crushed garlic that goes in
there okay
if we slice it thinly
what's going to happen is the garlic is
actually going to burn
i've got some really nice butter
mushrooms
so i'm just going to cut these into
quarters
okay i'm going to stick them in
the same pan as the lamb think of the
flavors going through
that incredible dish now that fat is
starting to render let's get a really
nice color on there
put the mushrooms and the garlic in with
a lamb the flavor of those mushrooms is
going to be incredible
now for the potatoes
time wise seven minutes to go
seven minutes or now we use touch of
olive oil with this
back up the gas okay
now if you haven't got new potatoes
normal potatoes will be fine
get some water in there
and literally
place those potatoes in half
and get them in
now i'm going to get some columnar
potatoes okay i'll
i've left the skins on i'm absolutely
good pan down there come down please
come down now how do i turn those
potatoes in something a little bit more
exciting
let me show you
take a nice red onion
okay slice it in half take off the roots
and then from there
look
just a nice little chop don't worry
about going too fast
the speed
you'll get there get the technique right
first and then increase the speed
listen i'm not expecting you to do this
in 10 minutes but i am expecting to do
it at 11 and a half
i can run 200 meters no pressure no but
hold on a minute you're saying ball can
run it in like 19 seconds i may take 24
seconds so it's fine
garlic on
and then again just gonna flatten it and
that's gonna go in with the potatoes
okay
really nice
now the water's brought into the peas
let's have a look at what's going on pan
down make lamb do you do it don't turn
it too early
don't turn that lamb too early i've been
worn by a separate juicer holly over
there i have to slow down
water in
peas go in okay
frozen peas in
and then from there lid back on turn
that gas up and turn that back now for
just over five minutes to go
tons
lift that first beautiful
cutlet look at that
sort of color on those things
so beautiful
so if you retire yeah i just forgot the
butter would you mind bringing a little
bit of buttercream i should've asked her
earlier
that mum makes dinner in 10 minutes
every night
with a baby in her hand
[Music]
please just
thank you now meg pan down please look
at the colors
okay so the garlic is doing this stop
the lamb is rendering down
a little touch of seasoning again now
we're turning it over
and now we're listening halfway through
and what i'm going to do now
is put a little touch of butter
into that lamb okay
no they're caramelized
they're burnt
stop that
mom never burnt her onions
look at the color of those now
okay useful color how's the time looking
good i've got four minutes
now as those things come back up to a
boil
i'm gonna crush them okay
and
what i'm gonna serve with this is just a
little touch of vinaigrette okay so
we'll keep this really simple look
a tablespoon of mustard okay just a tiny
actually thank you oscar
a little touch of cider vinegar when it
comes to cider vinegar
just a touch
extra virgin olive oil
in i want a nice relaxing sauce
and then from there
look
in the fridge i had this little
smoked chipotle paste that's got a
little bit of heat in it
put that in there simply done and then
put the lid back on
and give that
a little shake
now
look at that open that up
give that a little seasoning
okay they've got an amazing delicious
little marinade now look at that lamb
now come down mate come down please
[Music]
potatoes you freaked out
but the butter in there as well
and that's gonna help literally
those potatoes nice and crispy
now
if i touch there that lamb is already
medium rare and that's equivalent to
taking your pulse so touch touch it's
exactly the same take off
the gas
push it to a side
and look
i've got a little spoon of vinaigrette
going over that lamb
how nice does that look
beautiful
leave that lamb just sat there
marinating okay potatoes are nice and
crispy
and this
is where you see those peas turn
into something more magical
so if you glance for two minutes
into boiling water
drain off that water
put the pan back on the stove pan down
there pan down
and then
just look how crispy daddy look at that
that is not very that is bud
excuse me that's fun
oh that is
we have got three and a half minutes
left right piece back in
okay
from there
a little touch of butter okay crying
teaspoon of butter
okay
and then look come on please break
a little touch okay of creme fraiche
just
half a tablespoon
i'm going to do now is literally
create this evening
lightly and crush
crush those peas
and what's going to happen now it's got
this beautiful
sort of fresh
minty
delicious cream peas
and that creme fraiche gives a little
bit of acidity
and then look from there how messy you
are
you just flip cheese all over the
kitchen it's a kitchen some lemon zest
we're not going to be cleaning it up
dad ten minutes guys we've got 90
seconds to go please this is the crucial
moment correct the seasoning look at
that the creme fraiche in those peas it
is so beautifully well
now for the most exciting part when we
come to dress this
when we come to plate it
okay look at that lamb make pan down
please
beautiful from there
take that lamb out
oh my goodness oh oh hold on are you
over 10 minutes
i need another 90 seconds
mushroom remember we're going to use the
garlic guys okay mushrooms on
and then get your spring onions okay i
know i need another two minutes but
just slice them down
and throw those spring onions
in
to those potatoes okay soft
soften them nicely
and then from there
looking good
they
look
incredible now potatoes are nice and
crispy okay
very crispy
they're red onions guys really seriously
sorry they are not they are crispy
they've done with one or two minutes or
less but and then
finally
you get those peas
a nice spoon
of peas that lemon and crepe fresh at
the end honestly it works wonders
and then look
from there
take that light
smoky vinaigrette
and look
just glaze that
over
[Music]
come on i said you 10 minutes okay so i
need an extra minute i'm getting old
[Applause]
this is a beautiful part come on that is
the most amazing way of grilling meg pan
up is me now that's the most amazing
the most amazing lamb chops people pee
oscar will you stop making all that
noise in my kitchen please
honestly i'm a city to gino and fred
the most amazing soda potatoes with
caramelized red onions beautiful butter
mushroom's been cooked in the lamb juice
but here's the magic that lamb seriously
is tender and pink and there we have
dinner in ten and a half ladies what do
you think
dad yes
um where's the lamb sauce oh come on
tail's ready only you lost that we can't
no don't
we can't do lamb sauce in 10 minutes
well you know you can't serve lamb
without lamb sauce
i put a filly grill on there
get out
out the kitchen
out
seriously
seriously
seriously
how do you do lamb sauce in 10 minutes
mom could do it
should i take over
[Music]
you